today we're going to begin by looking at
sir Kierkegaard and we're going to look
at one of this very short essays the
present image which i think is a very
great way to introduce his lot as a
whole because of a lot of you to see
some of the basic themes not only for
Kierkegaard good for the existentialist
movement in philosophy literature in
general some of the basic things that
are going to come up over and over again
and you you see how Kierkegaard fits
them into some of his discussions of
publicity and the sort of age that were
according to his diagnosis currently
yeah it introduces another important
theme of his the dimension of the
religious without going too far into its
complexities so this is a really great
piece for starting to read Kierkegaard
with a lot of times people start with
trembling and things like that I think
this is in an easy asking this question
and he's answering and of course what is
the present age what is the moment in
time or the a block or the way of life
the structuring of society of human
consciousness all the opportunities and
possibilities they're afforded to us
what is them and I think that you know
given that this essay is almost 200
years old it's worth thinking about this
this question can this they actually
apply here in the present does this this
diagnosis
situation fit just as well in our time
or other things that would have to be
left out or another possibility is
Kierkegaard actually onto something that
may have shown him to be precedence to
be looking ahead to be seeing our time
in certain ways even better than his own
time I actually did this the case will
see why and then you know if you want to
think about that we have to guess how
would we actually conceptualize the
president page how would we get a handle
on our own time well the only way that
we can do that is by having some points
of comparison we can compare present
situations to what we can imagine so we
have real or at least our interpretation
of the real and then some sort of
imaginary could be a disco could be a
utopia that's one possibility
you may have some criteria afforded by
someone's theory or some on their stance
that allows you to critique the present
page but in general we have to look at
the relationship to the past and this is
something very interesting that's been
pointed out about modernity
most material that one of the things
that takes place it's not just a
contrast of the past but losing of the
past losing of a certain relationship
with the past that doesn't necessarily
occur the highest cultural levels but it
doesn't occur for the masses of people
so if you're going to be pointing things
out here in relation to the past but
also in relation to the present
possibilities whereas the side of the
present that is being overlooked being
left out not being seen in part because
it's not so easy to figure it requires
that there be an experiential an
existential component and we'll get to
that in a moment as well I just want to
race these beginning questions here's
another question that you have to ask
what does the present age what does the
way things are now mean for an
individual person and you have to ascend
so different ways one is very gentle
what does it mean for an individual per
se not necessarily this individual for
that individual but you notice that's a
very abstract way of putting it then
again Kierkegaard is an existentialist
so he is very comfortable with and would
actually see it as essential to to do in
genuine philosophy to say what does it
mean for me existentially in my concrete
situation again this takes us to this
question of
is this applicable now to us in new
millennium as it was for Kierkegaard
reading in the early 19th century what
does the the present age and the way
that it's structured what does it allow
me what is it an open up for me
what does it close along what directions
does a student has it steered me wrong
has it given me a sense of sufficiency
where there isn't sufficiency has it
given me desires that I want not to have
has given me ways of assessing and
evaluating things that are in certain
ways false or is this you know an age of
milk and honey where we actually
realized truth and everything is so much
better now than it used to be these are
real questions that have to be asked and
answered if you want to you know think
going back to the ancient Socratic
dictum know thyself and to examine your
life if you want to examine your life
and you want to live an examined life
you have to do so by thinking about not
just yourself not just your actions but
the time that you live in the
environment that area not just the
surroundings but the moral the ways in
which it allows you to develop as a
person what it tells you are right and
wrong the possibilities for action
or you might even think of it in terms
of the openings perhaps possibilities in
the sense of this is the way that you
want to go and we make this possible
maybe those aren't the same thing as
openings where one through action seizes
an opportunity that's being overlooked
by you might say the official party line
so all of it said by way of preliminary
what is it the presentation
what is determinate regarded Thanks
that's the answer this question the
present age is one it's one of you might
say the press that's where that sort of
limit point of the public goes it's in
the age of association it's an age in
some ways rebellion and revolt that is
gone on so long that there is not that
much
you actually rebelled and revolt against
in that classic sense that was even
going out of his own time in public is
composed individuals so there's going to
be this contrast between the public and
the individual in in this book the
present page and the public or the the
mode of being the moment of existence
the the environment that the public
creates conditions the possibility for
individuality for being a true
individual in this regard schism which
hasn't nothing to do with being an
eccentric nothing to do with expressing
oneself it has something to do with I
want to read you a passage from the very
end of this before we get to developing
this further he says when the generation
which itself desired to level and to be
emancipated to destroy the wording at
the same time itself has through the
skepticism of the principal Association
started the hopeless forest fire
abstraction when as a result of leveling
with this skepticism this generation has
rid itself of the individual and
everything organic and concrete and put
in its place humanity in the numerical
equality of man and man well the
generation has for a moment delighted in
this
panorama abstract infinity unrelieved by
even the smallest eminence undisturbed
by even the slightest interest to sea of
desert then the time has come for work
to begin for every individual must work
for himself each for himself no longer
can't the individual as in former times
turn to the great for colony grows
confused that is past
he's either lost at the dizziness of
unending abstraction or saved forever in
the reality of religion that is the
dilemma the choice the alternative that
Kierkegaard sets out and so our goal
here is actually to be trying to get
ourselves to that end point where that
alternative can be fake so in order to
do that we have to think about the
diagnosis produces of the present age
what is doing that how does the public
in general well he calls this the age of
making everything at the same level and
if you think about this is worth
dwelling on from there are different
ways in which you can level things out
and there are different types of things
that can be level so you know let's
think first of all about topography
right there's Hills there's valleys take
the hills throw them into the valleys
and
a little plane and everything is on the
same basic stratum that would be lovely
you can take numbers and and subtract or
divide that multiply them and they
wouldn't remain the same numbers anymore
what they but you would end up with with
the things you're working with being
love what about the people now it starts
to get more complicated because human
beings in here what does it mean to talk
about a lot of that facts then we talk
about equal rights that's a kind of
layman's kind of it's a way of saying
everybody should be placed on the same
playing field whether the right guess
that you would say freedom from search
and seizure or being allowed to vote
provided to one now you notice as soon
as we start doing this every time that
we start pushing things down or lifting
things up they start to it starts to
change the whole system and all the
other aspects other dimensions end up
being as well so leveling itself is a
controversial process and even the
nature of what counts as leveling is not
always clear but there is one thing that
you can say that is clearly ingrained in
modern liberal
Radek society which is this notion that
whether you call it all people are
created equal or everybody want to be
afforded the same rights or however you
want to look at it then we are all in
some important respect on the same
ground so one's one person's voice will
have not count for more unless perhaps
they're able to convince other people
that's the sort of ideal it used to be
that there were more authorities in more
traditional societies accepted on the
basis of being authorities modernity
isn't the age where everybody's
constantly asking by what right do you
tell me that who are you to put your
opinion across who are you to set
yourself here and me or that onlooker or
whoever down here and then reaction is
basically a level and your doesn't see
that is necessarily bad he's not saying
well we need to go back to the time what
is noting as a philosopher are the
effects of this there are not intended
consequences to this there there's a
sort of a process by which things get
out of control of it something is
sentence in motion this is very common
history you know somebody wants to make
some changes for the good and some other
things get sentence of motion which are
larger or structural harder to trap
heads around which affect us affect our
way in the world existed Kierkegaard
sees this in his time he has tied in
very much with what he calls publicity
or the press the press is a limit point
for any might say it's not just an
institution you know we often talk about
the Fourth Estate it's not just a body
of people out there it's a way of
approaching truth it's a way of
approaching reality it's a way of
approaching what it is that we claim to
know or value or pay attention to and
the press allows something to take place
for the first time that wasn't able to
occur in previous kinds of societies so
representation the ways in which things
are actually being reported or presented
or have some sort of representation some
sort of figuration in so many houses
press in somebody else's publicly saying
so in somebody else's we would say at
our time somebody else's web page of law
a newspaper things begin to exist and to
matter in so far as the
here some sort of medium now notice
there's a reversal taking place here
originally you would think and we still
have this sort of ideology that we teach
journalism students that the press
doesn't make reality it just reports
reality it responds to the importance of
things rather than sort of spinning it
and changing the importance of things it
doesn't interpret reality it goes out
and tries to investigate it and find it
back and this would apply to much an
investigative report this wouldn't apply
to say there was that really true you
know it's interesting if you look at the
history of advertisements goro the
advertisements were actually very boring
and the reason that they were very
boring is because the action tried to
just report the product and its prize
and its quality
to flop it didn't try to spin it they
didn't try to to change it and they were
competing against each other either
it wasn't saying you know let's compare
a brand x2 that changed over time with
the advertisement it's very clear that
the process altered and eventually the
advertising itself was pushing the
products actually a lot of the cost of
products appetizer
now what about other what about I'm not
just talking about reporting events but
talking about the importance say
cultural productions we're to be going
how do we know that we should see a
movie or a book is worth reading well
when we look for a review and if it
hasn't been reviewed at all what does
that mean very few people would actually
pay attention to it
which means it may not actually be very
important how do we know it actually is
important
well we rely on the public and this is a
leveling process because there's this
notion that well you know you just look
at what what a lot of people together
say and you know they're almost
anonymous but the more them them that
are involved with better because each
one of their votes counts for the same
each one of their opinions counselors
say ultimately it's it's saying that
maths counts because the individual
really doesn't count
nobody's opinion is better than anybody
else's except insofar
if it said that at the crowd and he
relaxed about people sort of falling
into this thing that he calls the crowd
which is form of irresponsibility later
section that's a way in which people can
be active he talks about them
associating with each other that allows
the agency that allows that activity
that allows them in some ways to feel
alive to feel like they may have because
one of the things that's going on with
Level II is if individuals don't really
matter except insofar as they fit into
somebody else's view somebody else's
sights then along with that goes a kind
of feeling and emotion and mood things
being empty something almost
corresponding to but nothing quite so
dramatic as that just daily life so
individuals find their activity in the
crowd of an association people also find
that they exist in the eyes that crowd
in the eyes of the public and they begin
to take their cues for who they are and
what value they have from the public so
this generates a situation in which
individuals become extremely forward you
know a lot of times we talk about
ancient society to medieval societies or
you know not modernized societies it's
having a set of cultural mores which
they sort of push on to the individual
the individual ends up sort of
assimilating these are identifying with
these or making them part of themselves
and they're therefore changing themself
in the process that's a relatively
benign process to appear to finding that
you only exist or feel like you exist or
can conceive that you exist and value
giving an I so that what other people
say not in yourself that's a pretty
dangerous place to any other and that's
a place where a lot of people are notice
this is a self-reinforcing because if
you have that feeling you're going to
seek out the ground you're going to
become part of the crowd you're going to
subordinate whatever eccentricities or
parts of yourself that have escaped sort
of the homogenous Asian that comes about
through the leveling process you're
gonna get rid of that so that you can
fit in Kierkegaard was looking at this
in his own time I think this is just as
big of a problem in our time may be
exacerbated by the just permeation and
penetration media everywhere and then we
look in the social let's look at the
contrast that he produces between the
putting Rapids and the present age she
says that this is going back to the very
beginning of it in the earlier stages of
our our culture our developer says the
dialectic of antiquity tended towards
leadership the great individual in the
mass is the free man in the slaves so
this is a common sort of a galleon
position Hegel said that in the ancient
world one man this tree and of course
the slaves under can be impressed with
Christianity all process of information
guarantee
effectively enlightenment all that
Kierkegaard has reacted to but he's
acknowledging at the same time so in
antiquity what you had with very
stratified societies in which people
could move but you know not too many
people could be on the top the people
who are on the top made value they
decided what other people had to do they
got to set the agenda you might say and
people will look up to the people would
want to be like them and oftentimes
people would strive to fit in into
something that the people from on top to
impose well and then he says in
Christian the dialectic of Christendom
tends towards representation majority
sees itself in its representative and
it's set free by the consciousness that
it is the majority which is represented
in this sort of self-consciousness so
there's something different that comes
about through Christianity and I don't
want to go too deep into this but
culturally that that's quite true I mean
doesn't matter whose philosophy
looking at where they see Christianity
coming into the Roman Empire it's good
thing or bad thing it certainly did
transform social consciousness and it
certainly did transform a category about
the individual did it totally radically
do that that were there no prefiguration
saying stoicism no that's not quite true
but it made it something that was
widespread that made it sort of the
default starting point for people
because in Christianity yet few actually
take it seriously you existed as a
person in the eyes of God even if you
were just a slave you know sweeping the
ground you still had some value whereas
in the ancient pagan world who really
didn't value that so far as you could
ascend status
he says the dialectic of the present age
tends towards equality and it's most
logical though mistaken fulfillment is
levelling as the negative greville a
relationship of the particular units to
each other I'm going to get to equality
in a moment I do want to talk about a
few other contrasts that come up with
this he talks about in the ancient world
in the medieval the world before Madeira
and he had really set it and the
processes have gotten underway
he says he's comparing us
he says the individual no longer belongs
to God to himself to his beloved to his
partner or to his science he's conscious
of belonging in all things to an
abstraction to which he's subjected by
reflection just as the surf belongs to
an estate so in the past one could find
their value one could find their meaning
through relationship concretely
with somebody else God presence that's
incentive to Christianity to oneself to
one's beloved to one's discipline what's
harder when science the level of the
process takes that away leveling process
subordinates the individual to something
less easy to figure less easy to point
it something more abstract something
love us you might say modern equality
the way Kierkegaard sees it is a sort of
interchangeability insofar as we become
completely equal we abstract away from
the individuality of the individual the
personality of the person you might say
what it is it makes me mean what it is
it makes you you we get away from that
and that's a dangerous thing to do
because as soon as we do that why have
me there why not just shuffle me off to
put somebody else in my place if we are
truly all completely equal in every
respect that none of us have any value
it's ironic because the leveling process
gets started by sort of recognizing the
value of that which has not been valued
you know if we say that it was unfair
that not everybody could evoke that we
want to have
software's that we want to let everybody
vote we're asserting that some people
have now their who have not been treated
as if they had value the effect of that
though is something different just
because you have a good intention
doesn't mean that it has the wrong and
good culture so we didn't modern
equality things become interchangeable
the individual becomes in certain ways
basically it becomes less than an
individual
he talks this is a great phrase it says
the individual in the masses in
antiquity had no importance whatsoever
the Post ending individuals signified
the law the present age tends towards a
mathematical equality in way in which it
takes so and so many to make one
individual
that's a brilliant way to put it we're
almost living in fractional life instead
of being able to take a stand and say
here's where I myself and taking
responsibility and I will act as an
individual we want to associate we want
to have the comfort of having people
behind us
because we don't feel ourselves to be
forward to take a stand we need not just
a comfort but the reliability the being
told that we're on the right track by
people and that tends to be this this
amorphous faceless Pollard he says quite
consistently people had themselves
together the most
purposes simply in order to put a
passive women to practice a few people
have themselves together the thing is
done then they dare do it so this is a
this is a failure of error failure of
courage and a deep level he's not using
the word courage but I think that it
doesn't make sense to talk about this he
also talks about people uniting together
he says the fact that people united
together and courage to meet death does
not nowadays mean that each individually
has occurred now he's explicitly talking
about this for even more than that the
individual fears the judgment and
protest of reflection upon is wishing to
risk something on his own now you notice
that use this word reflection many times
this is a a you know technical
philosophical term it means thinking
about oneself or thinking about yeah
what's the connection to the public does
the public reflect not really the public
just sort of you know meanders around
but the individual taking the public as
the criterion for whether they're doing
the right thing whether they're doing
the wrong whether there are things are
true or false
whether they should believe or not
believe they are engaged in the process
of reflection in which they internalize
the public this abstract public may
worry about
we'll say anytime that the individual is
asking themselves what would people say
not just what would this person say well
that person say what I care about what
would that person say who actually
dislike and maybe want to fax or
something like that instead of asking
that yeah asking what would they say
what would people say what if somebody
found out about this they aren't
engaging in a process of reflection on
the abstraction that is the poet maybe
this is accurate occurrence people
there's something amiss there's
something missing
in something knowing something wrong and
then Kierkegaard uses the word crisis in
talking about this is ongoing leveling
process let's you know be good there it
says the leveling process is not the
action of an individual but the work of
reflection in the hands of an abstract
of power you can calculate it you can
you can sort of figure out where it's
going to go because of that the
individual who levels down is insolvent
Golf in the process leveling cannot just
be somebody coming along and saying okay
now all of you are equal this is a
really important site it's something
that the individual chooses to do to
handle or herself in order to conform
themselves to this crowd the public
these other individuals
so the individual levels of esophagus
himself engulfed in the process and
while he seems to know selfishly what
he's doing one can only say to people
Hamas what they know not what they do
for just as collective enthusiasm
produces a surplus which does not come
from any individual there is also a
surplus in this case there's a there's a
meaning that gets produced when you put
a lot of people together responsible it
takes on a life of its own
let's look at another feature of this
leveling process is it possible to stop
it could we turn it back Kierkegaard is
astounded can dispense in that he is
looking to a previous age and saying you
know things were some respects better
than but he's not nostalgic in the sense
of saying we need to go back to them
he's saying that's gone we can't recover
that what we can do is what's possible
at the present he says who could stop a
lot of the process look look at
individuals first no single individual
and I need no outstanding individual the
sense of leadership will be able to
arrest the abstract process of love life
for it's negatively something higher
than the age of chivalry chivalry is
alive no one individual can hold back
this type can make it stop we're stuck
with we're stuck with that process we're
stuck with the gauge that it's produced
no society or association can address
that abstract power simply because an
association is itself in the service of
the leveling process modern forms of
Association are not going you couldn't
form a club to stop a level because as
soon as you've got a cloth a modern form
of Association evolved toward the
voluntary organization is called even
intermediate associations were
optimistic as soon as you form one of
those you were actually engaged in the
process of level a according to
Kierkegaard so that can't stop it either
not even the individuality of the
different nationalities can arrest it so
nationalists we can't deal with this her
on a hunger plate the abstract process
of leveling as a negative representation
of humanity pure it's this is a very
interesting thing to say the leveling
process is something that came about
historically it shows us something that
is part of our human nature it's real it
was waiting there to be revealed to be
on the fold it's not that's the good
news
if it were
so it is like it says a representation
of negative representation of humanity
the abstract leveling process that self
combustion of the human race produced by
the friction which arises when the
individual ceases to exist as singled
out by religion is bound to continue
like a treatment and consume everything
so this is the age that were stocked
with nothing can can stop this process
on its own grounds you could never beat
leveling in a popularity contest what is
the to to the principle of individuality
well he says the principle of intimate
individuality its immediate and
beautiful formation symbolizes the
generation outstanding a kind of an
individual m'as able to resist for a
while you can sort of the merger that
every once in a while you're not going
to change the whole process so it's
still possible to resist the principle
principle of individuality in its
eternal truth uses the abstraction that
quality of the generation to level now
and then that way cooperates we're going
to come back to that anymore says the
leveling process is as powerful or
temporary things are concerned as it is
impotent
we're eternal things are concerned so
here there's a moment of hope you can
say
on what's going on with this leveling
process he says in order that everything
should be reduced to the same level it's
first of all necessary to procure a
phantom the spirit of monstrous
abstraction an all-embracing something
which is nothing a mirage and that
phantom is the public it is only in an
age with as with witches without passion
yet reflected that such a phantom can
develop itself with the help of the
press which itself becomes an
abstraction and notice this is another
moment of hope that's well he says in
times of tunnels and passion and
enthusiasm even one of people desire to
realize we prove this idea and lay waste
to destroy everything even then there's
no such thing as a public there are
parties and they act arrogantly so so
long as there actually is some conflict
even if it's crazy conflict you know the
fruitless unlikely to win totally
utopian you're irrational there is at
least something going on that doesn't
reach this sort of limits but get away
from that yeah I think in modern and
late modern society we can actually have
in the zones of conflict where limited
meanings of merge for those who are
involved with them and they don't relate
everything to the public but then our
society
like a kindergartner
says the public is in fact real leveling
master rather than the actual level or
for whatever leveling is only
approximately accomplished it is done by
something the leveling process always
involves some group some people some
activities some forces working against
other forces and they don't realize that
they could sort of be sucked into this
process they think they're only opposing
this one issue but actually or they're
trying to produce this one change but
actually what's going on is a much
broader process that is going to
actually remove even the meaning of what
they're doing he says the public is a
concept which could not have occurred in
antiquity because the people of Hamas
incorporated
took part in any situation which arose
were responsible for the actions of
individual only when the sense of
association in society is no longer
strong enough to give life to concrete
realities is the press able to create an
abstraction the public consisting of
unreal individuals who never are and
never can be
the national situational organization if
you think about some of the great
controversies of our day when somebody
let's say very simple things when
somebody it's held up to be a great
person or held to be a terrible person
when you get down to the level of a kind
of freak of real individuals even a
certain groups certain interest
associations you will find that that
somebody can be held responsible
somebody actually says this is my deal
office but the public is larger when
somebody has become notorious or when
somebody has become celebrated then
there's a description of valuable that
nobody is actually responsible for that
happens through the press through the
operations of all these different kinds
of media that things get passed on ideas
get promulgated and eventually nobody
knows where it came from
nobody knows all anybody knows is
there's momentum going this way so we
better get in line he says the public is
a host more numerous than all the
people's together but it is a body which
can never be reviewed this is a really
critical point the public the crowd
people in associations individuals were
you know leveling themselves and acting
in accordance with this are in a certain
sense if you're responsible the public
bears
particular groups can but they're not
yet at the level of the public purse a
society of a these high knickers so
like it says a generation of people and
assembly of the people of meeting or a
man are responsible for what they are
and can't be made shamed there any
constant and unfaithful but public
remains a public a people an assembly or
a man can change to such an extent that
when they say they are no longer the
same the public on the other hand can
become very opposite and still be the
same on public that's what it means for
it to be an abstraction it's not
something that you can actually wrap
your head your arms the public is
completely irresponsible
so that means that that individuals who
take their cues from the public who
likey says the man who has no opinion of
an event of the actual moment accepts
the opinion of the majority or if it's
plural stone of the minority that sort
of thing is is sort of internalizing the
public and in doing so one is actually
oneself being irresponsible
irresponsible with other people but to
oneself as an individual and perhaps
even to something higher there is a
great danger here he talks about a great
danger to individuals says more and more
individuals owing to their bloodless
indolence will aspire to be nothing at
all in order to become the public that
abstract
or by form in the most ludicrous way by
all participants becoming a third party
this envelope they asked which
understands nothing and does nothing
itself and he goes on he talks about it
being sorta like you know jaded Roman
emperors waiting for more entertainment
more news more more novelty one more
things coming in on which it could pass
judgement and then allow it to move on
again nothing ends up having true value
really mattering and an individual who
ties him or herself in with that is
going to be living Kierkegaard thinks of
a very active life not realizing
something that is really important in
human life he figures this in terms of
the religious so this is where we now
turn to talking about relationship he
says that this current age presents us
with an opportunity as well as danger he
says that this abstract level in the
process it does level them but through
it each individual for himself may
receive once more
is education not about a religious
education like at a cases like here's
what we often leave anything but in
certain respects a negative education if
the public is obsessed with something
that's probably not something good to be
obsessed with you know if Tiger Woods
and his peccadilloes are you know in the
the pages and then you know debates
about gay marriage or at the pages that
is probably not what Kierkegaard things
that you want to be occupying their mind
with if you want to be a genuine
individual you probably need to think
about what's not being talked about
what's falling through the cracks what
is in the interspaces so he says the
individual may receive what's more
religious education and in the higher
aspire sense be helped by the examined
rigor also of the leveling process to an
essentially religious attitude for the
younger men who however strongly they
personally may cling to what they admire
is eminent realized from the beginning
that the leveling process is evil in
both the self astonishing invidual and
the selfish generation but then it can
also if they desire honestly before God
become the starting point for the
highest life for them it will indeed
become it will indeed be an education to
live in the age of lovely the age of
language allows us to actually see the
finiteness of temporary things it
doesn't tell us to look to Eternity
because it's hostile to eternity because
it can't even figure it or understand it
but it's doing us a favor by you might
say removing the idols by by lowering
them now even when it offers us you know
new ones the ones that it offers aren't
particularly good particularly
we think about it in terms of those of
the paths and their pageantry what they
had to walk the path to the imagination
this is not very good if American Idol
is the best we can do
forget it that opens up the door for
saying there's something bad
there's something more I need to try to
get a hold of this and your dad said
something really interesting there's two
other points about religion that I want
to hit on one is that he actually brings
up the Reformation and it criticizes
those who would say well you know the
Reformation happened we just have to
follow along those those sorts of lines
he says the Reformation produced heroes
the Reformation had a hero who paid God
behind of her his position as hero
yeah I think it's Lutheran right here by
joining up with him directly people buy
cheap indeed at bargain prices what he
had paid for so dearly
but they do not buy the highest of
things and then he says there's no good
calling on a whole gird on Scott or a
Martin Luther third day is over and at
bottom it's only the individuals
laziness which makes a man long to have
him back to be told what to do instead
everybody has to work out their
relationship to God in the age of
leveling on their own they they can
bring in things from other people of
course they don't begin from zero but
the age of love way has brought it about
that they're not stopped with looking at
what this person has to say
with this church chastity they actually
are now afforded the possibility looking
at it themselves without necessarily
being committed that saying I will have
been to this this is what to do the last
thing that I'm going to say that this
was not what were well into this this
notion of religious particularity
it's from close to the end he says that
there's a great danger here but also a
great opportunity it says anyone who
really wished it wishes to be helped to
attain the highest is in fact benefited
by undergoing such a misfortune by
undergoing the trend of age that were in
by seeing all the great things that we
might identify with brought low by a
bunch of people out there saying oh
that's not good
that sucks you know putting comments on
pages or whatever you want you know the
public is is you know not very well
educated has fairly or tastes so
anything that's truly great anything
that's truly beautiful it's not going to
be a great fan says anyone who really
wishes to be helped to attain the
highest is benefited by undergoing such
a misfortune and must rather desire and
even though people may be legible the
really terrible thing is the thought of
the many Linna that are or using the
native least I will not even mention
those who are lost or is any of it any
rate
those who play the part of the dog for
money but the many who are helpless
thoughtless sensual who their superior
lazy lies and never receive any deeper
impression of existence in this
meaningless grin and all those bad
people who are led into further
temptation because of their stupidity
that you come you even become something
important by commiserating with the one
who is attacked that even understanding
that in such a position a person attack
is always the stronger since this is the
bubbling process at its lowest before it
equates itself to the divisor by means
of which everyone is reduced to a common
denominator
the term alight was also sort of low and
yet that is not so because the unity
that everyone should really essentially
be because the unity is that everyone
should really essentially be a man
innocence be a genuine individual
somebody who's responsible not to the
faceless nameless human abstract public
but responsible to something higher
something eternal something that sees
the heart not just the outward
appearance that doesn't come to wrong
conclusions and judgments that can be
relied on whereas the public is
mercurial so Kierkegaard is was offering
an alternative view and this is again
very typically existential the
individual he has to somehow free him or
herself from the reliance that they
allowed to come over them buying into
other people's ideas buying into other
people's way of life
really thinking through and what you can
see here is that the existentialism is
in many respects at least in the hands
of Kierkegaard a return to the Socratic
idea of